on nous a annoncé d'incroyables
nouvelles sur le royaume il paraîtrait
qu au sud
une femme serait devenue reine il
paraîtrait aussi qu'elle a des dragons
et qu'elle est très très très très bonne
et aussi une armée de morts-vivants
place qui se diraient janot
accessoirement exacte et celle ci
il y aurait là une grande nouvelle on a
capturé un marcheur blanc attention un
vrai morts-vivants de glace de la
légende et tout si on découvre comment
tuer ces créatures pour aller à la
capitale fort des toiles et des
personnes c'est le moment qu'on
attendait tous les mystères sont de mise
bien cette de paysans alors ça peut être
de tout repos mais j'ai réussi à prendre
à la créature à parler notre langue
au début ces termes aux parties un mot
par là et un jour il a fait une présenté
hier on était tous là genre qu'est ce
qu'il a dit allez vous faire
sale et et ses quatre premiers mois
s'il n'arrête pas c'est cher je vous
écoute prend morceaux et je vous ai pas
retiré en forme de grâce à ce grade
on sait que j'avais à faire ça on s'est
vraiment mérité devient hospital ces
bonnes âmes qui finissent en spirale
vous méritez même pas de vian certes tu
vas compris la suite c'est froid alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
marcheurs blanc n'utilise pas d'argent
du coup on a dû trouver autre chose aux
marcheurs blanc s'est tu nous dis
comment vaincre tes frères nous
t'offrons cette tarte aux pommes ce joli
dessin fait par y aurait une hache
mais non non une bougie parfumée j'ai
trouvé que ça il a accepté de nous
dessiner son point faible
en échange de trois plumes de perroquet
1/2 sandwich à la dinde et de sa nickel
du coup on a fait venir un seigneur de
la capitale pour lui parler de notre
découverte
il paraît qu'ils ont trouvé une solution
pour vaincre l'armée des marcheurs blanc
ça pourrait tout changer
après pour moi ça reste des clodos le
loup siffle un champ de miséricorde
le lion et le cerf se côtoient de
nouveau les gens de la capitale se la
pète beaucoup dans ces cas là on n'en
voyais aurel pour dire bonjour en cinq
phrases il est imbattable
les effluves de la rancoeur des lions ne
peuvent soutenir les années perdues dans
les rivières détour vente eu la truite à
certains naviguer dans des eaux
houleuses mais ces écailles reste
vigoureuse ok mais c est qu ils peuvent
elles soutenir la patte d'un lion
furieux parce qu'ils mystères sont
dennis portel gagne pas il ya 3 2 pour
qui je sais pas si parfois la tortue
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que pour
les tuer il faut les plantes et la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on n'a aucune
idée de ce que c'est je me casse
là on espérait vraiment pourra regagner
la capitale mais finalement on va rester
ici
[Musique]